in the history with the history of art
at least here in Europe I cannot talk
the other part of the world art was
supposed to be an expression of timeless
beauty and you can see it in the work of
Michelangelo and Raphael Rembrandt and
whatever there is no longer the case the
the main objective of art is not longer
took of contemporary is not longer to
create something of an extreme beauty so
why I what happens I think that the
interpretation of beauty has been so
narrowed in the contemporary sense okay
if you have any knowledge about the art
Inge you gypped so that is not about
beauty
that's about we would say about truth
the truth could be inner truth so that
can be been being some kind of religious
meaning about or understanding of
universe and the relationship between
human beings and the universe which is
not really about a so-called beauty the
beauty has been over-emphasised over
exaggerated by a purse hua society I
think it's always about choose and the
moral and the beauty so without truth
and morals no such thing as Beauty one
of the big questions concerning
contemporary art is if it's no longer
about this boudoir idea of beauty how
can we make a distinction between good
art and best art or how can we know what
what what is hard I think for me art is
about a necessity as
it's about it's about struggle it's
about human struggle it's about the deep
layers of a humanity and because our
aesthetics always relate to those
questioning you know of our philosophy
or aesthetics moral judgment so that's
how I feel what art is about you fail
your thought is that market value or
it's something else
well I don't think they're they're
talking about the value of art they talk
about value of the canvas eNOS is
different I think I think the Ventoux
the if it's life would be totally
insulted by this connection and the
value of art cannot be defined it's not
possible it's only can be measured in in
how it relate to our own reality our own
struggle otherwise is just a [ __ ]
you know so if you saw this piece in
Africa or in Asia may being in the
market people would just step on it and
nobody would care you know whatever what
piece of [ __ ] is that
but here of course you have a lot of
other feelings religious feeling but I
heard a spot by somewhere given the
religious practice so even people
doesn't know where this piece is so it's
it's art being treated as a stock stocks
or or for people who won't buy it for
some other reason which is
understandable but it's nothing to do
about a value of art it's the famous
work of art by Weiwei - how was his own
and about - Solomon - son to a hundred
before ok what would have been its
market value
no value I told you the art has no value
the market value of that photo it's
already so long time ago it's not
existing anymore what I hope to
understand is so to drop this 2,000
years old why is it that you want to do
destroy because I have another one you
know as a tentacle is insane me that's
not different
okay so when you have a plenty of them
than you yeah it's one too many
you